ed a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video mamma mia che voglia
di tornare in giappone che ciò sono
andato quasi romeni che è passato un
anno come mai non sono ancora moro siamo
tornati io dice questo è il mio piccolo
spazio in cui ritorno nel gioco in
giappone senza in realtà a tornare in
giappone lo faccio con la mente seduto
nella mia camera che attenzione non è la
mia camera ma è il mio studio quindi
neanche quello
cosa ha detto il gatto costa ha detto il
gatto c'era niente potrà dirlo subito
vabbè comunque minchia ram ed è spuntato
io non so nulla di tutto questo ma
quanto sarebbe figo viveri sta a casa
[Musica]
sì
ti prego vi prego che ti ho appena visto
qualsiasi con qualsiasi cosa sia la
compro qualsiasi però comunque a vedere
cos'è voglio tutto proprio tutto tutto
datemi tutto così prende sta roba come
si prende la torta di pikachu la voglio
la voglio iguana and co fichi riguarda
nell'acqua e cambia colore
oh my god iguana enrico fermi cervi
allora allora c'è questa cosa e della de
agostini ho veramente sentito due
bambini giapponesi urlare de agostini
veramente ho sentito vi prego
[Musica]
io non avrò mai più di così il giappone
più di oggi
[Musica]
io non dormirò mai più la notte ve lo
giuro su dio io mica vi sono cagato
addosso questa è la prima cosa vi dico e
la seconda cosa che questa marionetta è
fottutamente uguale a mio zio toni
uguale un saluto a mio zio è il primo
tempo che il primo tempo a posto shampoo
in faccia per caricarsi del secondo
tempo
l'opzione per la pelle e ti sembra di
essere allo stadio anche quando non sei
allo stadio
[Musica]
pensate che storia esattamente mio grado
di ubriachezza quando bevo una fanta
poco nota meno a questa è partita bene
rega essere partita bene questa è buona
silvio zero to write
se questa è fatta da dio non so cosa sia
ma fermi fermi ce l'ho ce l'ho
dov'è allora spetta modulo circospetta
postura corretta postura scorretta
io ma cosa si sta facendo a guerra tutto
sto bordello per un mix hacking cosa
no non stop non voglio stoppare giovani
cosa sto vedere cos'è ma cos'è eviti
prima hanno messo rimarr che rotola ma
perché
[Musica]
ma dai il g1 l'hanno fatto che qua ma
come la pista giapponese va bene ok ei
[Musica]
va bene
[Applauso]
[Musica]
morte
tanto si vedeva chiaramente che la
bambina faceva proprio schifo
semplicemente l'hanno detto devi fare
una faccia come se tu volessi mangiare
per il pet traverso e l'ha fatto però si
sta tenendo tantissimo anche qui
[Musica]
si no
non so
[Applauso]
[Musica]
ragazzi non ho capito niente so solo che
ho fame andiamo avanti
io io io non ce la fa io non posso vado
in giappone metto le pubblicità caso
quando in giappone a depressione non
esiste una cazzata gli dicono che
lavorano un sacco di sonde pressione
verona le pubblicità così dai non può
essere depresso cioè ti pare uno va dal
barista chiede una birra e gli arriva al
proraso ma cos'è che l'ha lanciato chi è
quello io non ho neanche più io non ho
io non ho neanche più la forza il
commentario non so che non so più cosa
dire cosa c'è dopo la morte questo non
c'è più non c'è il paradiso in fe questo
c'è vado a spruzzare la schiuma da barba
nel cesso arrivo credo sia un tè questo
non ne sono sicuro ma che ha azzeccato è
ed è l'ora azzeccato the all'arancia
promette bene
verrei di tutto orange di questa ecco
questa è tra l'altro e facciamo questa
precisazione questa era la pubblicità
che sponsorizzava del tè all'arancia e
come è fatta la pubblicità una che si
beve tè all arancia e giusto e perché
prima mi hanno spruzzato della schiuma
da barba nel cesso però è ok non ho
capito niente di quello che ha detto
[Musica]
il vecchio ha esultato chissà cosa avrà
detto qualcosa di vero c'è anche l'arte
in questa bevanda in questo tutti e
bevande che vengo in giappone non ha
niente da mangiare solo bevande royal
miti se non stai calma sono di vendermi
nel film il devi stare calmo
innanzitutto stai calmo giotto mattea
bellissimo mi è piaciuto un sacco
però mi è venuto un sacco di voglia di
magda anche e soprattutto su network
finalmente qualcosa da mangiare
finalmente finalmente solo da bergamo
non era mangiare da bere ma basta papa
stava voglio mangia fatemi deve cosa
mangiare
basta bere basta avere basta bere basta
per le pubblicità e rari taglieresti
liquidi fanno un sacco in bagno
giapponese non si sa perché bevono solo
patron solo qui cita di rob è davvero
così amata tedesco
quindi quindi meno cose da bere ma non
ho capito cos'è credo sia latte però
lighty york o finalmente una roba che
non e da bere ma pare tutta la
pubblicità della macchina e poi tirano
fuori da bb da fitch è un panda che
ballo li pone finalmente non era la vera
era una macchia
c'è sempre qualcuno che piange conferma
perché era troppo piccante finale anche
io farei così dopo la vasta ficcante ai
fermi burt non c'è niente non combini
grand soleil avanti con chi ne sa cosa
avrà mai detto madonna gatto si sveglia
trova da mangiare un filtro dell'auto
cosa ai massimi gc tutti restano non ho
capito niente
hai finito si ok bello store bambino
peccato che vedremo nel prossimo
ragazzi io rimango estasiato estasiato
sempre di più da ogni che ogni volta che
vedo la pubblicità giapponese e c'è un
motivo vero che video vi sia piaciuto a
me personalmente tantissimo scegliamo le
fosse bisogno di pubblicità giapponesi
voi scrivete via canale sia già dalla
campagna nina così non vi perdete
neanche un episodio di tutta questa roba
per che bloccava h meritano come sempre
ci vediamo al prossimo video bella
ragazzi
[Musica]